así que terminamos muy repentinamente el
último vídeo porque ya llevábamos mucho
tiempo y era justo dar una pausa pero en
donde nos quedamos fue simplemente en
calcular esta tercera integral de
superficie y quedó como una integral
doble respecto a los parámetros r y
theta de hecho los valores sobre los que
estamos integrando son de 0 a 1 para er
y de 0 a 2 pi para theta porque así
estamos completando todo este círculo
unitario rellenito está está completito
todos los puntos que están dentro de
esta circunferencia entonces pues vamos
a seguir vamos a seguir ya que estamos
en en la recta final entonces esto va a
ser igual a la raíz de 2 por la integral
de 0 a 2 pi y ahora vamos a calcular una
anti derivada de esto y esto es muy
sencillo porque si distribuye si
distribuimos este producto nos queda r -
r cuadrada coseno de teta y entonces
sólo hay que encontrar una anti derivada
de esta expresión
entonces si lo hacemos con el mismo
color rosa una anti derivada de r pues
será re cuadrada sobre 2 menos una anti
derivada de r cuadrada porque el coste
no es una constante para fines de
integrar respecto de r entonces una anti
derivada de r cuadrada es r al cubo
sobre 3 y ahora hay que multiplicar el
poli coseno de teta y todo esto hay que
evaluarlo de 0 a 1 y luego integrar
integramos respecto de teta y vamos a
vamos a hacer esa vamos a evaluarlo en 1
y en 0 entonces esto va a ser igual va a
ser igual a la raíz de 2 por la integral
de 0 a 2 pi y cuando evaluamos ere
cuadrada entre 2 en 1 simplemente nos da
un medio menos esto evaluado en 1 cuando
eres igual a 1 simplemente es un tercio
un tercio del coseno de teta y luego
habría que restar evaluando en cero pero
esto evaluando en cero
y esto también entonces ya no hay nada
más que hacer simplemente ahora a esto
que nos quedó hay que integrarlo
respecto de teta sobre el intervalo 0 2
pi y esto va a ser igual a la raíz de 2
que multiplica vamos a encontrar una
primitiva de esto una primitiva de un
medio o una anti derivada es un medio de
teta menos la una una anti derivada de
coche 93 seno de teta entonces nos queda
un tercio seno de teta seno de teta
entre cero y dos pi entre cero y dos y
por lo tanto vamos a ver qué pasa cuando
evaluamos en dos pi
esto simplemente será la raíz de 2 que
multiplica cuando evaluamos en 2 pi en
vez de theta ponemos 2 pi y dividimos
entre 2 nos queda pi y ahora cuando
evaluamos seno de 2 pi es cero si
evaluamos ahora en cero esto nos da cero
y seno de cero también es cero entonces
ya aquí tenemos un redoble final porque
la tercera integral simplemente nos
quedó como la raíz de dos por pi
entonces si regresamos a lo que
empezamos hace muchísimo tiempo esta
última parte esta última de aquí es no
es otra cosa más que la raíz de dos por
ti así que toda esta integral de
superficies que empezamos a ver hace
como mil videos es igual a la parte roja
que es 0 la parte azul que es tres y
medio y luego la parte morada que es
raíz de dos por pi así que 3 pie entre 2
+ raíz de 2 por pi es el valor final
nuestra integral de superficie